the latest polls are to be believed it
might be working with the remain camp
edging ahead to a three point lead I
really do see a parallel between what's
happening in the United States and
what's happening here
it is Yuka against the political class
and they are so politically correct I am
so tired they are so United around
wanting to be popular
it is as if the BBC is part and it's
thinking of the political establishment
they are the most dishonest people in
the world and we are the one party in
British politics challenging this usual
thing for census do we like the media
do we hate the media
Deitrick fruitcakes and loonies and
closeted race it's basically you could
put half of Trump supporters into what I
call the basket of deplorable the
English pronunciation of ferrets rather
than the rather policy for insanity one
that he seems to prefer people want to
see borders they don't necessarily want
people pouring into their country
we just got too many people we can't
cope bringing jobs back to our countries
and they take jobs nothing's
american-made anymore people want to
have controls not just on the numbers of
people who come but I'm a type of people
who come time is overdue to develop a
new screening test extreme very that is
absolute wrong proved over and over
again we actually you have the charisma
of a damp rag such a nasty West fine and
the appearance of a low-grade bank clock
I call them little marker we don't know
you crooked Hillary Clinton we don't
watch you fly a jet and the sooner
you're put out the ground the better is
after 43 years the UK has voted to leave
the European Union not only did it win
but it won by a much bigger margin than
people thought it would happen